Well, we're gonna start on a very hot topic.
Virtual dating.
Uh huh.
So Refinery29, just published their guide
to a perfect quarantine Zoom date
and Ross, they have some tips, which I like
'cause I'm like, "Don't be vague, give me specificity".
And all my friends who are single are doing this.
So I want all these tips.
All right, so before the call,
take time to set your frame, adjust your lighting
so that you don't have to worry about it
like once the call starts.
Fair, do you have a ring light?
You know those ones where.
I don't, do you?
Of course, hello, it's 2021.
You gotta get a ring light.
No, right?
Okay, also try to make it feel like a real date.
You can be specific, it's a coffee date or a wine date.
Listen, are we dry or are we wet here?
You know what I'm saying?
You can use Netflix Party function
to watch a movie together.
Oh, I didn't know that existed.
Yeah, it's a whole thing.
There's so much now that you can do
if you wanna date on like,
people, they're trying to use it as an excuse,
like, "Oh, it's so hard and it's pandemic."
No more excuses, everybody.
This year, it is possible to date.
You remember, I started dating somebody
at the beginning of the pandemic?
That's right.
And we would do this thing where we would like,
I'd have like Uber Eats delivered,
we'd have dinner at the same time.
And if you're just starting to date somebody brand new,
this is great because say the date's going really poorly,
you can just be like, "Oh, well, oh, oh,
"Oh my wifi, cut out. I'm sorry."
And then peace.
I haven't done that on Zoom
but I've definitely done that on the phone.
You faked it?
(all laughs)
You faked a no signal?
All right, well, we've got the perfect menu
for any Zoom date in today's Food News.
Ooh, there it is (indistinct) with the yum yum yums.
Okay, what if I told you that you could have
wine and cheese and it would be good for you?
My butt would say, "No way."
Correction, it would say, "Pinot, you didn't."
But it's true, I can, in fact,
Martha Stewart Living reports that
wine and cheese can actually improve your brain health.
Yep, a scientific study conducted over 10 years
showed that it has real benefits for cognitive function.
Which if you ask me, sounds like pretty Gouda news.
Yeah it does.
So I just decided now
every time I go to happy hour
I'm just going to say, "I'm taking my meds."
Yeah.
Right?
I bet the people in that study over 10 years are happy
because they're not pretending
that they can deprive themselves of everything
and still find joy, because you can't.
Well, they're probably happy
'cause they're a little tipsy.
Okay, well check this out, Ross,
TikTok is full of treasures.
It really is.
Totally.
I love this latest design tip, okay?
People are making their homes extra cozy
with these GE stained glass light bulbs.
And they're each hand-painted
to lend a soothing colorful look to the room.
I really am into this.
What do you think?
Well, I hate overhead lighting
and I hate a room that's too bright at night.
It's gotta feel dim and intimate.
This is a no brainer,
I've never had this or seen this and I'm so obsessed.
Oh, I just had a bright idea.
(all laugh)
My mom's father, Shenyi,
he was a stained glass maker also.
Really?
So this, yeah,
this really reminds me of him.
(upbeat music)